Traducteur: eric vautier
Relecteur: Gabriel Tallineau
Avez-vous fait bon voyage
pour venir jusqu'ici ?
Emprunter nos réseaux urbains,
qu'ils soient routiers,
de transport en commun,
de télécommunications, ou électriques,
n'est pas toujours une partie de plaisir.
Surtout quand il s'agit de venir dans
des contrées lointaines comme Saclay !
(Rires)
Pourtant, aujourd'hui ensemble,
nous allons voir que les balades
effectuées dans ces réseaux urbains
peuvent être l'occasion d'un jeu,
en un sens que je vais vous définir.
Pour jouer dans ces réseaux urbains,
il faut commencer par avoir des joueurs.
Et là je me permets un postulat osé :
tout homme naît fondamentalement joueur.
C'est un des rôles de la société,
et de certains de ses chercheurs
un peu excentriques,
de donner ce goût du jeu,
et de l'entretenir,
de montrer la vie sous une forme ludique,
et d'y fixer de bonnes règles
pour arriver à une solution
collective efficace,
pour qu'on ne fasse pas
de ces réseaux urbains
le lieu d'une promenade
purement individuelle.
Et là vous vous dites sûrement déjà :
« Mais comment en est-il arrivé là,
être à tel point côté de la plaque ?
(Rires)
N'a-t-il pas pris le bus 91.06
pour venir jusqu'ici ? »
(Rires)
Revenons à mes racines
pour comprendre ce virus du jeu.
À 10-12 ans,
bien au chaud sous la couette
et éclairé d'une faible lampe de chevet,
je relisais un magazine
trouvé je ne sais où,
et aux noms évocateurs :
Vassalopet,
Transjurassienne...
Ces noms ne vous disent sûrement rien
- en fait, j'espère pour vous.
Il s'agit de courses de ski de fond
dans le froid, sous la neige,
où il faut parcourir
jusqu'à une centaine de kilomètres.
Vous l'avez compris,
dans mon cas,
le virus du jeu s'est construit
autour du sport.
En particulier,
autour de grands défis sportifs,
dans lesquels les limites
personnelles ne sont dépassées
que grâce à un élan
et un soutien collectifs.
Dix ans plus tard, naturellement,
je suis sur la ligne de départ
d'une course tout aussi mythique,
la SaintéLyon.
Je suis donc là
entouré de charmants camarades,
avec une lampe frontale,
parce qu'en plus, ça se joue de nuit.
Bon, le principe est simple,
je vous le rappelle,
on part de Saint-Étienne,
et on arrive à Lyon,
avec pour seuls alliés ses baskets,
et donc la lampe frontale.
Je suis sur cette ligne de départ,
avec ma lampe,
-10 degrés,
et un T-shirt.
J'arrête là la description de
mon propre virus du jeu.
Je suis sûr que chacun d'entre vous,
sous une forme personnelle,
détient aussi en lui cette fibre joueuse,
une fibre joyeuse.
Lorsqu'on regarde le déchaînement
des foules avec Pokémon Go,
les forces vives de la nation
sur leur portable,
jouant le matin en allant au travail,
on ne doute pas de cette fibre joyeuse,
joueuse d'ailleurs aussi.
Mais arrivé là, qu'en fait-on ?
Ce que je vous propose aujourd'hui,
que je vis dans mes développements
mathématiques, et dans mes défis sportifs,
c'est de faire de la vie
dans nos réseaux urbains un jeu.
Là, il vous manque sûrement un truc :
c'est quoi, un jeu ?
Alors sans entrer dans des développements
mathématiques trop difficiles,
je vais donner une définition
théorique de ce qu'est un jeu.
Ça commence par un ensemble de joueurs,
que nous sommes tous.
Ensuite, ce sont des actions
à la disposition de chacun de ces joueurs.
Et enfin,
c'est un coût
pour tous les joueurs.
Et dans ce coût, vous voyez intervenir
deux dimensions.
D'une part, une dimension individuelle ;
elle ne dépend que
de notre propre action.
Et une dimension collective,
elle dépend toujours
de notre propre action
mais aussi de celle de tous les
joueurs qui nous entourent.
Ne pas se coordonner
dans les réseaux urbains modernes,
c'est aller au-devant, tous ensemble,
de coûts collectifs importants :
le temps passé sur la route,
la pollution, le bruit.
Bon, mais observez un petit peu plus
cette formule magique,
et notamment le paramètre alpha.
Ô magnifique alpha !
Dans les jeux urbains,
l'alpha, c'est la vie !
Pour le comprendre,
disons que le coût collectif
représente la pollution dans nos villes,
le coût individuel, une notion de
confort et de temps passé
lorsque nous parcourons ces villes.
Fixer alpha égale zéro,
c'est ouvrir un boulevard
à la dimension individuelle
et aux 4x4 sur les artères
parisiennes, soit dit en passant.
Fixer au contraire
alpha égale plus l'infini,
c'est pousser dans le sens
de la dimension collective.
Choix difficile qu'est celui de alpha,
et qui cache des inégalités criantes :
certaines personnes,
au-dessus de la mêlée,
ont la possibilité de se soustraire à
un alpha fixé par la puissance publique.
D'autres personnes
ne peuvent le contourner.
Mais laissons là ces débats politiques,
et maintenant, je vais honorer
la promesse que je vous ai faite :
vous montrer que les balades
dans nos réseaux urbains
peuvent être mises sous la forme d'un jeu
au sens que je viens de vous définir.
Vous êtes venus à Saclay,
vous avez vu Saclay.
Dans quelques heures,
il va falloir repartir.
Je vous propose de faire le trajet
du retour avec moi de manière ludique.
Comme tout bon travailleur à Saclay,
lorsque vous sortirez,
si vous n'avez pas de voiture,
pas de chance,
vous avez deux options :
vous pouvez prendre
une navette inter-entreprises
qui ira, via le réseau routier,
directement Porte d'Orléans,
ou alors de tenter
les transports en commun,
avec le bus 91.06,
puis le RER vers Paris.
Le travailleur de fin de journée
n'est pas fou,
il veut rentrer au plus vite chez lui.
Il sort donc son magnifique smartphone,
effectue deux recherches :
l'une pour estimer
combien de temps il mettrait
pour aller Porte d'Orléans en navette,
l'autre pour le même itinéraire
effectué en transports en commun.
Généralement,
il choisit l'option la plus rapide.
Là, vous vous dites sûrement qu'il
s'agit d'un choix purement individuel,
vous n'avez pas encore le virus du jeu.
Laissez-moi vous contaminer !
En fait,
cette décision dépend bien sûr
de tous les choix faits
par ceux partis avant vous.
S'ils ont pris l'itinéraire
que vous comptiez emprunter,
il va y avoir des gros bouchons.
Il faut interagir.
Une façon de faire pour interagir
est de voir cette situation comme un jeu.
Les règles du jeu sont définies
par un opérateur urbain,
qui est maître du jeu,
mais aussi arbitre, nous allons le voir.
Bon, maintenant, supposons que
nous avons pris la navette.
En chemin, très rapidement,
nous allons sûrement tomber
sur ce panneau.
(Rires)
Ce panneau,
c'est un concentré de théorie des jeux.
Imaginez l'opérateur jouant avec
les valeurs de temps de trajet
sur ce panneau.
Par un simple changement de valeur,
il peut faire perdre ou gagner
quelques minutes
à des milliers de Franciliens,
rentrant chez eux, pressés.
Il peut bien sûr dire la vérité,
annoncer les temps de trajet réels.
Mais tous les gens vont se ruer
sur l'option la plus courte.
Naturellement, quelques instants
plus tard, un bouchon.
Coordination nécessaire !
Aux États-Unis, ils font d'autres choix.
Ils montrent les tarifs
pour emprunter les voies :
plus de temps de trajet.
Là,
le choix public est
complètement différent.
En France,
la valeur du temps passé sur la route
est de 10 euros par heure
pour tous les automobilistes français.
C'est le même alpha.
Aux États-Unis,
chaque personne peut choisir son alpha.
Si on a les moyens, on paye.
On prend la voie express
et on ne vit pas les coûts collectifs.
Est-ce vraiment le jeu
que l'on veut jouer ?
D'autres solutions existent,
je vous rassure,
notamment covoiturer.
Alors là, souvent,
des voies sont réservées
aux voitures bien remplies,
au moins deux personnes à bord,
mais là attention, méfions-nous.
Rappelez-vous,
les hommes sont très joueurs.
Parfois tellement joueurs
qu'ils en deviennent tricheurs :
jusqu'à mettre leurs poupées gonflables
à la place de leurs chers covoitureurs
sur la place du passager,
et s'engouffrer vaillamment
sur la voie réservée aux covoitureurs.
Naturellement, l'opérateur urbain,
le shérif local,
se doit d'agir,
de jouer son rôle d'arbitre.
Ma chère poupée, vous êtes hors-jeu !
(Rires)
Rappelez-vous, nous sommes dans la
navette, nous arrivons à Porte d'Orléans.
Terminus !
Tout le monde descend !
Arrive le dernier kilomètre,
souvent le plus long.
Et là, dirigeons-nous vers un système
de vélos en libre service,
nous sommes à Paris,
notre vélo s'appelle Vélib.
Nouveau champ de bataille où
les décisions individuelles des hommes
se confrontent :
prendre un vélo rapidement,
le déposer rapidement.
Ce fut mon premier travail de chercheur :
quelques mois à imaginer les hommes
utilisant les vélib comme des joueurs,
pour arriver à un superbe théorème.
Je le remets.
Aujourd'hui encore,
j'en suis tout ému :
il ne m'est d'aucune utilité
quand, tous les soirs,
j'enfourche un vélib,
et je veux rentrer chez moi au plus vite.
J’en retiens deux messages.
Le premier :
prouver l'existence d'un équilibre,
c'est bien beau mathématiquement,
mais à court terme,
ça n'aide pas la collectivité.
Deuxième message :
nous ne pouvons pas jouer face
aux décisions individuelles de tous,
dans le cas d'un réseau Vélib,
ou de tout autre réseau urbain.
Il faut trouver une bonne information
moyenne sur la situation de ces réseaux,
ici, le nombre moyen de personnes
utilisant les stations.
Mais nous devons dépasser les limites.
Ce théorème n'est pas suffisant,
je l'efface.
Finissons à pied.
Nous arrivons chez moi devant la porte,
je l'ouvre,
et avant de monter à pied
comme tous les soirs,
- six étages tout de même -
j'ouvre la boîte aux lettres,
une facture de la copropriété.
Une note pour l'ascenseur.
Nouveau coût collectif,
partagé au sein de l'immeuble.
Et un nouvel alpha,
lié à la valeur,
disons l'étage auquel on habite.
Vous l'avez compris,
nouveau jeu.
Les règles sont simples :
nous partageons le coût collectif de
l'ascenseur proportionnellement
à l'étage auquel nous habitons.
Chaque soir, lorsque je monte à pied,
l'ascenseur ne monte pas,
je gagne donc de l'argent.
Mais ce que je découvre
en lisant cette facture,
lorsque je monte à pied,
tous mes voisins gagnent de l'argent.
Je suis ravi.
Bon, mais nous sommes au sixième
devant ma porte.
Je vous laisse là, je suis désolé,
je suis un petit peu fatigué.
Petit conseil au passage :
jouer avec excès comporte des risques.
Mais bon, pour moi, azimut canapé.
Et là, à peine assis,
une petite voix lancinante dans ma tête :
« N'as-tu pas oublié le jeu
le plus important ? »
Je fonce à la porte :
« Entrez, vous êtes les bienvenus !
Une dernière partie ? »
En effet, ma thèse a proposé d'amener
le jeu dans un nouveau monde,
de le sortir
de ses applications traditionnelles,
place aux réseaux électriques.
Expliquons ce jeu par une tâche simple :
laver une chemise.
Demain, c'est TEDx,
je dois laver ma plus belle chemise.
À l'ancienne, je pourrais prendre
cette chemise,
la mettre dans le bac
et appuyer sur le bouton.
Erreur !
Ou plutôt « Peut mieux faire ».
La jouer collectif
dans le monde électrique,
c'est ne pas oublier notre enseignement
du catéchisme électrique.
Pour ton prochain,
le réseau, tu ne détérioreras.
Pour sa santé,
une bonne tension, tu maintiendras.
Pour notre bon air,
les moyens de production non polluants,
tu solliciteras.
Oui, mais, et alors ?
Ma thèse a proposé de faire jouer
entre elles des consommations
électriques dites flexibles,
- que l'on peut décaler dans le temps -
machine à laver, véhicule électrique,
lave-vaisselle, pas de souci.
Ces consommations flexibles vont jouer
entre elles dans le quartier.
Elles vont entamer une discussion.
Itérativement,
sur la base d'une information collective
dont j'ai montré la valeur,
elles vont discuter ; tant qu'elles
ne sont pas d'accord,
la discussion continue.
Heureusement, très rapidement,
la discussion s'arrête,
elles ont convergé vers une décision
qui pour chacune
est stable individuellement,
et bonne collectivement,
les meilleures
pour notre système électrique.
Ainsi,
chacun de nous détiendra
une partie de cette solution collective
pour un monde électrique meilleur.
Et tout ça, depuis notre canapé,
rassurez-vous !
Mais alors, au terme de ce long voyage,
revenons tout de même
sur mon postulat fondamental :
sommes-nous prêts à nous montrer joueurs
dans ces réseaux urbains ?
Nous l'avons vu,
en regardant les panneaux sur l'A6,
en pédalant en vélib,
en prenant l'ascenseur,
nous jouons déjà sans le savoir.
Mais sommes-nous prêts à jouer aussi
avec nos consommations électriques ?
Pour amener un élément de réponse,
je propose une balade,
montons tous ensemble à Montmartre.
Et là, depuis les hauteurs
spatiales de Montmartre,
nous voyons la Terre illuminée.
À cet instant, comme dans la première
montée de la SaintéLyon,
que je me retournai,
et que je voyais le ballet des lampes
frontales s'animer,
que ça donnait une image
de l'effort collectif en jeu,
à cet instant, des hauteurs spatiales
de Montmartre,
voir cette multitude de lumières
dans la pénombre mondiale,
ce nombre potentiel de joueurs,
me donne une grande lueur d'espoir.
L'arbitre l'a vu :
les joueurs sont prêts.
Il siffle le coup d'envoi :
« Ensemble, gagnons
cette nouvelle partie ! »
Merci.
(Applaudissements)